[Música]
qué pasó con sus salones que fue de
estos espacios de en donde nos
encontrábamos regresarán como los
conducimos hola soy jessica gonzález
actualmente soy learning manager en
kidzania empresa que se dedica a la
educación y al entretenimiento con
presencia en más de 25 países y justo
eso trabajar en educación es a lo que me
he dedicado en los últimos 30 años y hoy
vengo a contarte sobre algo que nos
ymbro y removió por completo a todos los
docentes llegó el 2020 todo parecía
normal niños y niñas en sus escuelas los
maestros preparando todo para el cierre
del ciclo escolar con broche de oro y
justamente pensábamos que la segunda
parte del ciclo escolar es la que más
utilizamos para tener trabajo que en
todos estos pendientes que normalmente
tenemos pero de repente algo pasó nos
mandaron una casa nos llevamos nuestras
cosas y pensamos que sería por unos días
unos meses pero el tiempo pasó y nos
dimos cuenta que lo que estaba pasando
era diferente y que tal vez no estábamos
ni preparados para eso comenzamos a
correr tratando de entender este mundo
virtual empezamos a ver un nuevo uso
para redes abrimos grupos de whatsapp en
donde nos dimos cuenta que la
comprensión lectora no era precisamente
una fortaleza empezamos a entender que
todo había cambiado y que tal vez no
estábamos ni preparados para lo que
estaba sucediendo intentábamos enseñar
matemáticas o contar una historia y a la
mitad de nuestro relato se colaba el
sonido del gas del fierro viejo y de la
basura le entregamos nuestra casa a
través de una pantalla la escuela se fue
a la casa y la casa se hizo una escuela
llenamos espacios de nuestros hogares a
través de una pantalla y los convertimos
en salones y en algunos pocos casos en
salones vacíos en donde montamos un
nuevo centro de transmisión un cuartel y
aquí seguramente muchos extrañaremos
estos salones y esos espacios que tanto
añoramos pero valdría la pena preguntar
si realmente aprender solamente se hace
en un salón que en qué otros lugares
podemos realmente desarrollar
aprendizaje relación conectar con
nuestros alumnos y hacer muchas más
cosas a través de la educación
y justo en ese espacio virtual es en
donde hay un nuevo ambiente de
aprendizaje lleno de herramientas
tecnología y apoyos que las manos de un
maestro realmente cobra en magia un
maestro actual es uno que tuvo que
reinventarse es uno que muchas veces
tomó clases busco consejo con alguno de
sus hijos para aprender a utilizar una
computadora justamente estamos en esto
tratando de entender todo lo que podemos
encontrar y la enorme variedad de
recursos a los que podemos tener acceso
se modificó lo que enseñamos lo que
aprendimos y cómo lo hacemos los modelos
híbridos llegaron la virtualidad está
aquí con una fuerza vital enorme y es el
momento de aprovecharla imagínate la
maravilla de poder llevar al gran cañón
oa la monalisa a tus clases de poder
entender el mundo y llevarlo justo a
través de esa ventana que es la pantalla
en nuestras manos está la enorme
habilidad de poder llevar el mundo a
nuestros alumnos para que para que las
niñas puedan saber que puedan ser
científicas aprender de matemáticas o
ser ingenieras y que los niños puedan
bailar y saber que también pueden
cocinar serían enormes investigadores
sacaron de la comodidad pero ahora hemos
desarrollado enormes habilidades tal vez
nos quitaron nuestros salones pero nos
dieron enormes conocimientos que tal vez
no esperábamos tampoco estamos
desarrollando habilidades para poder
modelar lo que es el siglo 21 a todos
ellos que tenemos a nuestro cargo
incluso aquellos que no saben parte de
la tecnología o que en este momento no
pueden estar conectados y que también
son nuestros alumnos que también son
nuestra responsabilidad ahora somos
creadores y curadores de contenido
digital porque la unita ya tampoco
funciona en la virtualidad buscamos
recursos especiales y los adaptamos a
nuestros alumnos a sus salones a sus
intereses a todos sus gustos y eso es
fundamental hoy en día en esta
virtualidad que llegó para quedarse hay
algo muy importante la tecnología es una
herramienta maravillosa que justo en
nuestras manos es en donde cobra vida
tal vez te quitaron el salón pero ha
quedado el corazón en esto en las
huellas que puedes dejar en ellos y
además seguramente he disfrutado
muchísimas cosas has hecho
presentaciones y tal vez también cajas
que nunca te habías
y justo eso es maravilloso cuando tú
puedes ver que algo que pensaste que
planeaste se hizo realidad y que además
lo disfrutaron muchísimo juntos eso es
algo que te quiero compartir
por ejemplo en kidzania hace unos meses
junto con un gran equipo de trabajo
tuvimos un campamento en línea en donde
había más de 5000 niños conectados y era
maravilloso ver todas las mañanas la
pantalla llena de cuadritos con caras
emocionadas y sonrientes nos mostraban
sus trabajos el primer día era increíble
lo recuerdo profundamente cuando todo lo
que planeamos imaginamos y creamos
estaba sucediendo y además lo
disfrutaban nos hicimos parte de su día
a día sin querer hoy somos creadores y
curadores de contenido digital estamos
ejerciendo una capacidad crítica para
poder escoger lo que es más conveniente
para ellos justo en esa capacidad
crítica es que estamos ejerciendo lo que
se conoce como ciudadanía digital que
son todas las normas de comportamiento
que están relacionadas con la tecnología
y que eso es una habilidad crítica del
siglo 21 que debemos modelar en todos
los niños y jóvenes
por maestros y por padres de familia
también estas habilidades del siglo 21
son fundamentales para todo el uno y
esta ciudadanía digital es lo que
realmente nos hace ser yo mismo delante
y detrás de una cámara con todos mis
valores y mediática conocer cuál es el
mundo que verdaderamente les quiero
mostrar porque justamente podemos llevar
el mundo para ellos pero lo que tenemos
que considerar es cuál es el mundo que
vale la pena compartirles incluso se ha
acuñado un nuevo término conocido como
de etiqueta y es justamente lo que nos
ayuda a entender todas estas normas de
comportamiento que tienen que ver con la
ciudadanía digital es entender cómo voy
a hacer yo y llevar esta ética en todo
momento delante y detrás de la cámara el
escenario cambio la práctica práctica
debe hacerlo los contextos se
modificaron y es algo importantísimo
para que podamos juntos crear un nuevo
mundo virtual pero uno que sí vale la
pena compartir lo importante es entender
el poder de los dedos sobre un teclado y
una pantalla y la enorme responsabilidad
que eso conlleva muchos dirán que no es
lo mismo aprende
cuando estamos conectados estar en línea
y efectivamente no lo es el ambiente de
aprendizaje virtual es uno muy diferente
que requiere de diferentes tecnologías
de diferentes herramientas conocimientos
y habilidades que tal vez ni siquiera
nos imaginábamos que teníamos o que
hemos desarrollado en todos estos meses
esa incomodidad que ha dado también
conocimiento te ha dado nuevas
oportunidades y te ha dado nuevas formas
de crear y llevar con mejores contenidos
mejores informaciones e ideas a todos
tus alumnos justo eso es lo que tenemos
que aprovechar ahora porque es lo que
tenemos y es lo que está sucediendo algo
importante considerar es también utiliza
todas las enormes herramientas que hay a
tu disposición y busca algo para tu uso
personal para poder administrar tu
tiempo para manejar tus recursos de
mejor manera conviértete en un gran
expectiva dor o investigadora explora
juega con todo lo que puedes encontrar
utilices enorme capacidad crítica para
entender cuáles son las mejores opciones
que puedes ofrecer para ti y para tus
alumnos
y ahora es incluir a todos y hacerlo de
una manera activa
nosotros tenemos el poder para lograrlo
se llevaron nuestros salones pero sabes
qué pasó aprendimos les aprendimos y re
aprendimos muchísimas cosas son los
maestros diferentes hoy en día y esto es
algo que también tenemos que guardar en
nuestro corazón para poder ofrecerlo a
nuestros alumnos la tecnología en
nuestras manos es mucho más que una
herramienta es lo que le da vida
justamente de esta parte digital es en
donde podemos recobrar toda su fuerza
vital tal vez extrañamos los salones que
teníamos esos espacios que significaban
muchas cosas presenciales démosles un
nuevo tono a todo el ambiente virtual a
este ambiente de aprendizaje que también
tiene una fuerza única y especial
extrañamos los salones esos espacios
físicos que tal vez nos quitaron pero
sabes algo importante nuestro salón hoy
es el mundo salimos de las cuatro
paredes y estamos en un lugar mucho más
maravilloso si sabemos aprovecharlo si
sabemos admitirlo y si lo abrazamos
adecuadamente hoy estamos conectados hoy
estamos en línea y ya somos maestros
digitales
gracias